[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans sens public
l'émission qui donne du sens à
l'actualité nous sommes le mardi 6
février et nous sommes ensemble pour 1
he et dem de débat et de décryptage de
nouveaux visages pour une nouvelle
politique alors que le Président de la
République et son premier ministre
remodèle leur équipe gouvernementale
nous nous demanderons où va le
macronisme car en un mois Emmanuel
Macron a donné le tourn à sa majorité
comme à l'opposition alors revirement ou
renimement nous ferons le point dans
notre premier débat dans la seconde
partie de cette émission nous par
leuront santé en passant à la loupe les
annonces faites par Gabriel Atal dans sa
déclaration de politique générale de la
taxe lapin pour les patients indélicats
aux obligation de garde pour les
professionnels de santé en passant par
la régularisation des médecins étrangers
que vaut l'ordonnance du docteur hatal
ce sera le thème de notre second débat
mais tout de suite place à notre premier
débat alors que le Président de la
République tente de relancer son
quinquena sa majorité s'impatiente et
s'interroge que reste-t-il du macronisme
celui des origines celui du en même
temps celui de la disruption celui de
l'Europe celui de l'écologie seule
certitude Emmanuel Macron lui prend son
temps comme nous le raconte Fabien RER
l'acte 2 du remanimement n'en finit pas
de se faire attendre presque un mois
après la nomination de Gabriel Atal
toujours pas de ministre en vue pour des
portefeuilles aussi cruciaux que le
transport ou le logement on a quand même
toutes les crises qui défilent sur la
crise du logement moi j'attends le
ministre du logement pour répondre à
cette crise du logement en l'occurrence
on attend toujours il y a dans le
discours de politique général du du
nouveau Premier ministre des annonces
sur le logement qui sont des annonces
bienvenu ou contreversé mais en tout cas
politiquement forte il faut quelqu'un
pour les porter enfin c'est et pendant
ce tempslà on fait deapsonnage politique
on fait enfin bon je je sais pas à quoi
il joue mais voilà il va être temps
d'être sérieux quoi pour l'exécutif le
casting semble en tout cas avoir des
allures de casse-tête entre les
exigences des alliés modemes et horizon
la demande d'un rééquilibrage à gauche
ou la tentation de débaucher chez leslr
il y a aussi peut-être des véléités de
débauchage individuel pour encore plus
voilà alimenter le le Marigo politique
je n'ai jamais été approché j'ai lu
comme tout un chacun que mon nom était
parfois cité dans la presse débauchage
individuel ou pas la gauche elle
n'attend plus rien du nouveau
gouvernement qu'elle accuse de mener une
politique de droite c'est le fond qui
compte et pas pas la photographie et le
fond il est à droite et à droite tout et
c'est de plus en plus marqué à l'unisson
les oppositions dénoncent la forme de ce
remanement interminable nous sommes sous
un régime de l'humeur du prince le
prince a décidé de faire attendre les
ministres potentiels les membres du
cabinet les journalistes le microcosme
s'agite et le prince s'amuse est-ce que
c'est encore la République à quoi
ressemblera le gouvernement à talau
complet réponse dans les prochaines
heures ou les prochains jours
ou macroni on en parle ce soir avec mes
invités bonsoir Sophie cagard bonsoir
vous êtes journaliste éditorialiste
politique au point et auteur de la
tyrannie de la médiocrité aux éditions
de l'Observatoire j'accueille à vos côté
Benjamin morurel bonsoir Benjamin
constitutionnaliste maître de conférence
en droit public à l'université Paris 2
àas c'est ça voilà auteur de la France
en miette aux éditions du SER bienvenue
aussi à Lucile Schmid vice-présidente du
S tank la fabrique écologique et auteur
autrice de Emmanuel Macron à contetemps
chez Bayard et puis Émilie zapalski
notre éditorialiste qui m'accompagnera
tout au long de cette émission alors au
commencement était la révolution c'était
le titre de l'ouvrage du candidat
Emmanuel Macron en 2016 aujourd'hui et
pour commencer cette émission si vous
deviez chacun choisir un mot pour
définir le macronisme ce serait quoi
Sophie kangard la véorussion on
tourne Luc Schmith
désorienté désorienté
Benjamin recherche d'issue ça fait deux
mots mais je crois que ça définit bien
aujourd'hui ce qu'il pense Ilie moi je
dirais proté formme qui prend les formes
un peu en fonction du contexte et de et
de la demande alors je le disais au
début de cette émission en un mois
Emmanuel Macron a beaucoup secoué sa
majorité l'opposition au point de donner
un peu le tourni à tout le monde on va
faire le point chapitre par chapitre et
d'abord commencer par le fameux
dépassement vous savez le en même temps
la loi immigration
rachidti l'entrée de Catherine Varin au
gouvernement a fait pencher le
macronisme de plus en plus à droite
est-ce que c'est la fin définitive si
j'ose dire du en même temps Lucile
Schmid toute la question c'est de savoir
si le macronisme c'est seulement
Emmanuel Macron c'està-dire que c'est
sûrement la fin du en même temps du côté
d'Emmanuel Macron il y a eu un
infléchissement à droite clair mais le
sujet c'est au fond qui peut prendre la
suite d'Emmanuel Macron est-ce que ça
peut être parmi ces jeunes macronistes
parmis ces jeunes députés qui restent
des personnalités qui veulent au
contraire reprendre la formule initiale
qui était au fond de gouverner au centre
et le centre c'est pas l'addition de
mesures de droite et de mesures de
gauche puis ensuite uniquement de
mesurees de droite et donc tout le sujet
c'est au fond est-ce que le futur du
macronisme c'est autre chose qu'Emmanuel
Macron parce que pour vous aujourd'hui
le gouvernement et sa politique sont de
droite ils sont clairement de droite et
surtout je pense qu'il y a quelque chose
autour de l'absence de conviction
c'est-à-dire que lorsqu'Emmanuel Macron
gagne en 2017 il a d'une certaine façon
prouvé un certain nombre de de choses il
y a un programme il y a des convictions
sur le renouvellement de la classe
politique sur la question de l'ouverture
à l'islam par exemple sur la question
migratoire et là il y a un côté Q
par-dessus tête dans ce début de enfin
dans ce début un peu avancé de 2ème
quinquena qui donne le sentiment que ce
qui compte c'est l'absence de conviction
et c'est pas parce qu'on fait du en même
temps c'est-à-dire que peut-être
l'expression au fond est malheureuse
mais si on veut gouverner au centre il
faut avoir des convictions et un projet
et il ne faut pas se renier
effectivement ou se contre contire ou
donner le sentiment que les convictions
compent moins que le débauchage et en ce
sens pour moi l'avenir du macronisme
c'est de prouver qu'il a un contenu qui
est un contenu stable dans le temps et
une méthode de gouvernement alors Sophie
cagard si on poursuit ce que ce que dit
Lucile Schmidt est-ce que pour vous
c'est un virage idéologique basé sur des
convictions ou plutôt comme le dit d'une
approche pragmatique on va dire la
France est à droite et donc on s'adapte
bah je pencherai très très fort pour le
pragmatisme en effet parce que si on se
demande ce qui reste du macronisme bah
en 2017 on pouvait c'était compliqué
mais on pouvait quand même voir les
contours et aujourd'hui il y a plus de
contour enfin c'est le c'est le flou
absolu le régime de retraite universelle
terminé la réforme de l'État qui est
enfin qui est une des clés du de la
réussite éventuelle du de la Révolution
macroniste c'est-à-dire que si vous
faites pas de réforme de l'État l'INT
tendance de ne suivra pas si j'ose
direidé débloquer la France idé de
débloquer la et puis enfin Emmanuel
Macron à l'époque où François Fillon
voulait supprimer des centaines de
milliers de fonctionnaires disaient mais
mais pas du tout c'est pas la bonne
méthode ce qu'il faut faire c'est
réformer l'État et ensuite effectivement
il y aura moins de fonctionnaire parce
qu'on sera devenu tellement efficace
tellement agile que tout ça ira très
bien et ben ce pilier aussi a disparu et
dernière chose parce qu'on on va vers
les élections européennes enfin moi je
suis quand même si
par la différence d'approche entre
2019tie on va vir bien sûr on fera un
chapitre sur l'Europe d'accord Benjamin
pour vous c'est un échec du président ou
c'est simplement que notre système
politique j'allais dire les institutions
sont trop fortes bah je crois qu'il y a
des réalités institutionnelles mais que
surtout il y a des réalités électorales
Emmanuel Macron conquière un espace
politique d'ailleurs dans un climat
politique très particulier il faut se
souvenir de la primaire à gauche qui
envoie un candidat très polarisé pour le
Parti socialiste benoî Hamont de l'autre
côté un candidat très polarisé pour la
droite avec qui plus laffire Fillon et
donc ça dégage un espace centriste qui
permet de faire cette union des centres
qui n'a jamais été tout à fait
équilibrée de tiers centre gauche un
tiers centre- droit en 2017 ça s'inverse
en 2019 on verra bien ce qu' lancera en
2022 des élections européennes il reste
un tiers de gauche pour vous il reste
aujourd'hui dans l'électorat quand on
regarde les dernières élections en effet
un/ers de l'électorat macronien qui
reste un tiers venant plutôt du centre
gauche il est très très risqué de
négliger ce tiers c'est pour ça que il
faut pas non plus trop présager de ce
qu'il fera dans quelques mois lors des
élections européennes pour le reste bien
je dirais qu'on touche la limite de ce
qu'on appelle les mouvements un
mouvement c'est très pratique
aujourd'hui dans les dans tous les pays
européens et cetera vous avez un leader
il est pragmatique il voit l'espace
électoral et comme il y a pas des
militants comme il y a pas des
structures lourdes du parti derrière qui
lui disent n'oublie pas juris à dit ou
n'oublie pas de golad et bien il peut
s'adapter à l'électorat il peut prendre
une idée la mettre sous le tapis au
contraire la mettre en avant parce que
ça plaît à l'électorat les sondages
disent il faut y aller et donc on y va
le problème c'est que en faisant ça il y
a pas de corde de rappel voilà vous
construisez sur le court terme et vous
construisez pas sur le long terme vous
construisez évidemment pas un après et
puis vous construisez pas non plus un
personnel politique fidèle qui vous
permet de conquérir des collectivités de
tenir une assemblée de structurer
également derrière une administration on
y viendra peut-être et donc infz vous
prenez le pouvoir tout seul mais vous
êtes tout seul au pouvoir et être tout
seul au pouvoir bah ça permet pas de
faire bouger l'état parce qu'on fait pas
bouger l'état tout seul Émilie après
tout cette clarification elle était
peut-être nécessaire non oui et mais
c'est peut-être aussi pas forcément que
l'échec de ma a lancé ça c'est peut-être
l'échec du en même temps aussi
c'est-à-dire satisfaire à la fois une
politique un peu libérale et satisfaire
à la fois les services publics et et on
a bien vu qu'au fur à mesure des crises
il y avait un État providence qui était
mis en place par Macron et quand la
crise s'arrête comme un peu maintenant
on resserre la vise sur l'assurance
chômage on resser laav sur le RSA donc
quelque part c'est un peu
schizophrénique comme mouvement c'était
très alléchant cette promesse de vente
elle était très alléchante en 2017 c'est
vrai c'était le côté pragmatique on va
prendre un peu à droite un peu à gauche
mais finalement on se rend compte et
j'allais dire en rigol comme le
communisme que c'est joli sur le papier
mais c'est inapplicable et on ne
comprend plus parce que ça donne en
effet quelque chose qui qui n'a pas de
conviction qui n'a pas de corps on parle
souvent de colonne vertébrale qui
n'existe pas parce que d'un coup on fait
ça et puis après on se dit ah ben non on
va faire ça finalement peut-être que
c'est en même temps il était un peu fou
mais il est pas faisable il est pas
tenable sur le plan pratique pour
gouverner la France parce que notre
classe politique est pas adaptée à ce
genre de de compromis à ce genre de
coalition oui en nous écoutant je me
disais qu'on peut pas rendre non plus
Emmanuel Macron responsable d'une forme
d'infantilisme de la classe politique
française et c'est pas non plus nos nos
institutions mais le spectacle de
l'Assemblée nationale avec cette espèce
de fragmentation puisqu'on a dit que
cette Assemblée nationale aurait été
digne d'être élu à la proportionnelle ça
donne aussi le sentiment que du côté de
l'ensemble des opposition comme du côté
de ce qui constiue la majorité il y a
une forme d'incapacité à trouver des
coalitions je rappelle qu'Élisabeth
borne avait dit qu'elle allait essayer
de gouverner en créant des coalitions de
projets on il y a quand même une
cinquantaine de textes qui ont été
adoptés
par oui mais pas les plus importants et
et on a vu les batailles rangées enfin
ce qui s'est passé par exemple sur la
loi migration cette motion de rejetù le
rassemblement national s'associe à la
gauche ou en fait ceux qui ont des
options complètement inverses
s'associent pour ne pas discuter un
texte et ne pas débattre moi ça m'a
beaucoup marqué je pense qu'il y a donc
une forme d'infantilisme qui ne tient
pas seulement à Emmanuel Macron qui
tient aussi à la sociologie du pouvoir
en France on va pas non plus toujours
chanter les louanges de l'Allemagne mais
en tout cas surtout que la coalition va
pas très bien mais en tout cas dans les
pays dans lesquels il y a un régime
parlementaire on peut dire que ça
fonctionne un petit peu mieux pour
organiser du collec en tout cas il y a
du collectif et il y a la la capacité à
se dire bon là il y a un gouvernement au
fond qui est ministre dans dans ce qui
se passe Gabriel hatal ça pouvait être
une très bonne idée de nommer un jeune
premier ministre mais dans ce
gouvernement qui n'est toujours pas
nommé il y a quelque chose qui éteint
les féatal inexorablement et du coup on
se dit mais qu'est-ce qui est en train
de se passer alors qui n'est pas nommé à
l'heure où nous parlons mais qui devrait
être prochainement bientôt si t que
cette succession de coou tue la capacité
à en tirer une signification parce que
justement c'est l'aspect coou c'est
l'aspect je sais même pas si c'est du
pragmatisme c'est tout simplement me
semble-t-il une manière c'est pour ça
que je parlais de désorientation il y a
un coup là puis un coup là puis un coup
là et puis on se dit tiens mais
peut-être on va régresser et du coup ça
ne donne ça empêche de donner un sens à
la politique et par rapport à ce que
disait Benjamin Morel sur la façon dont
on va quéter l'électorat dont on fait
une démocratie d'opinion on peut aussi
avoir déplaire à tout le monde on peut
plaire un coup plaire un coup là puis
finir par déplaire à tout le monde en
attendant tactiquement euh ça a plutôt
fonctionné ça a fait de morts le Parti
socialiste et les républicains Sophie
Kangar ah sur ce sur ce plan-là sur le
plan de la déconstruction on doit on
doit on doit applaudir quand même euh je
veux dire c'est c'est vrai que le projet
euh transparent d'Emmanuel Macron qui
était de faire exploser euh les deux
partis de gouvernement a assez bien
fonctionné c'est presque ce qui a le
mieux fonctionné euh dans son projet
mais en effet le le problème c'est que
euh on finit par se demander si
finalement Emmanuel Macron n'est pas le
plus excusez-moi l'expression politicar
de tous les présidents qu'on a eu or
c'était un peu inattendu c'est-à-dire
qu' gros il était dégagiste et il nous
promettait le nouveau monde alors on
peut comprendre la désillusion d'un
certain nombre de ses électeurs qu'on
voit je crois dans beaucoup d'enquêtes
d'opinion et même la désillusion d'une
part de ses compagnons de route parce
que entre aller chercher Rachid Dati
aller chercher Catherine Vautrin c'est
c'est débages çait très politicien et et
on n'imaginait pas ça d'un d'un homme
qui à qui on reprochait justement de
n'avoir jamais été élu de ne jamais
avoir été dans les combinations
politiques qui se effectivement qui s'en
orgueillissait comme vous le disiez de
ne pas créer de partis politique Burk
mais un mouvement et en fait ENF il
passe sa journée à faire ce que ce qu'on
appelle de la popole c'est la fin du
dépassement d'une certaine façon c'est
aussi la fin de de du recours à la
société civile puisqu'on voit revenir ir
des profils très très politiques dans la
macronie oui parce qu'au risque de
déplaire aux téléspectateurs la
politique c'est un métier hein c'est pas
le politiste qui vous dira le contraire
c'est-à-dire que écrire un amendement
c'est un métier diriger un ministère
c'est un métier c'est un métier que vous
pouvez apprendre sur le tard il y a pas
forcément d'école et évidemment vous P
passer par vous pouvez passer par l'enat
mais avoir roulé votre boss dans les
collectivités territoriales pendant 20
ans vous y forme en réalité bien mieux
donc avant onavait un cursus horum
politique et ce cursus hor room vous
permettaz bien de tenir les ce type de
choses qu'est-ce qui se passe en 2017
vous avez des ministres qui souvent ben
n'étaient pas réellement dans le système
ou avaient été collaborateurs d'élu au
mieux et ont réduit le le nombre de
conseillers ministériels et on les des
dans les cabinets ministériels et puis
on les spécialise dans la communication
ce qui fait que beaucoup d'erreurs du
premier quinquena sont souvent liés à
des dysfonctionnements ce qui montre que
là-dessus en effet il y a un aspect
métier politique et lorsque vous n'avez
pas de parti lorsque vous n'arrivez plus
à attirer des politiques de l'extérieur
et bien vous vous retrouvez en panne
sèche de l'autre côté vous avez un
électorat on l'a dit qui doute parce que
l'électorat d'Emmanuel Macron il faut se
souvenir de deux choses et peut-être ce
sont des faiblesses qu'il n'a pas
analysé au départ quand vous regardez
les enquêtes de 2017 c'est un électorat
qui parmi tous les électorats des grands
candidats votent relativement par défaut
donc c'est un électorat qui doute hein
en fait je n'ai pas d'autres candidats
sur cet espace politique donc je me
replie sur Emmanuel Macron pour
l'électorat centriste c'est pas un
électorat acquis justement qui a une
forte identité politique il vot
socialiste parce qu'il a toujours été
socialiste il vot goliste parce qu'il a
toujours été goliste là on est sur
quelque chose de nouveau et donc des
vanissant l'autre élément et bien c'est
que cet électorat là aujourd'hui quand
vous regardez les enquêtes d'opinion et
ben vous avez environ un Français sur
deux qui ne se situe plus sur l'axe
droite gauche et donc on a un électorat
très fluide très volatile donc
l'effacement d'éclivage plutôt fonctionn
en partie alors oui et non c'est-à-dire
que paradoxalement ces clivages tiennent
beaucoup plus sur l'électorat centriste
que sur les autres électorats et c'est
un électorat d'Emmanuel Macron qui est
un électorat facilement mobilisable
plutôt AG CSP+ mais c'est un électorat
qui n'a pas de réserve dans l'abstention
donc vous tenez sur un électorat qui ne
croit pas en vous de toute éternité un
électorat qui n'a pas de réserve et donc
pouvez pas surmobiliser et un électorat
qui plus est qui reste clivé justement
par des vieilles identités politiques
droite gauche et qui donc
potentiellement si vous l'envoyez pas
les bons signaux peut vous abandonner
alors on va passer à un autre mot clé du
macronisme des origines la disruption
est-ce que Lucile est-ce que vous êtes
comme Sophie on sait qu'au fond il est
assez classique C Emmanuel Macron c'est
un président un peu à l'ancienne ou
est-ce qu'il vous surprend encore
non il me surprend pas du tout mais ce
qui me m'abassourdit et qui qui me qui
m'angoisse c'est la disruption créée par
le rassemblement national c'est-à-dire
que Emmanuel Macron nous vend la
disruption en 2017 puis au fond ce qui
est en train de se passer c'est quand
même que ce qui bouleverse le champ
politique c'est la normalisation du
rassemblement national eux ils ont
réussi leur disruption ils étaient un
parti Oni et aujourd'hui ils sont
cravatés et ils arrivent à apparaître
raisonnaablees dans une assemblée
nationale en furie donc il y a quelque
chose là qui se passe qu'il faut bien
prendre en considération sur la
fragilité de notre démocratie et le
sujet important pour Emmanuel Macron
c'est que si au nom de sa disruption
supposée il a organisé une disruption
qui permett le rassemblement national
aujourd'hui gagne des des parts de
marché parlons comme ça et donne le
sentiment de porter des conviction alors
qu'ailleurs tout est fluide ça c'est un
problème et ça c'est un problème
d'ailleurs qui dépasse le macronisme qui
concerne la gauche et la droite parce
que moi je suis quand même assez frappé
de voir que la droite a couru après le
rassemblement national sur la loi
migration en disant c'est ma loi c'est
pas votre loi qu'ensuite en ce qui
concerne tout ce qui se passe sur la
question des agriculteurs le
rassemblement national prône encore
enfin dit encore que c'est sa victoire
idéologique donc on a le sentiment au
fond qu'on est en réaction par rapport à
cette disruption qui révèle le fait
qu'on pourrait
devenir plus vraiment une démocratie
donc la disruption c'est pas seulement
un mot c'est ce qu'on en tire ce qu'on
en fait avec opiniatreté et là je trouve
qu'il y a eu beaucoup trop de fragilité
et comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure de
désorientation et peut-être
effectivement de hulos d'entre soi en
fait le sujet c'est de sortir de l'entre
soi alors de l'action de l'action de
l'action avait promis Gabriel Atal au
lendemain de sa nomination je propose de
regarder une image cet après-midi après
son déjeuner à l'Élysée avec le
président de la République le Premier
ministre a trouvé le temps de
télécharger une nouvelle application be
pour ne pas la citer et de faire un
selfie dans son bureau de Premier
ministre un jour comme aujourd'hui il
était attendu un peu plus tard aux
questions au Gouvernement est-ce qu'au
fond
il y a que la communication qui reste de
la de la disruption initiale Sophie Kard
B c'est c'est quand même difficile à
dire parce que enfin comment vous dire
je je voudrais juste dire quand même
pour essayer de trouver quelques
circonstances à Emmanuel Macron qu'il a
quand même été un président de crise
incroyable et que donc enfin quand on
des crises pr il a quand même été enfin
disons que ses ambitions étaient très
contrariées par des faits extérieurs et
indépendant de sa volonté pardon c'est
pas tout à fait votre question mais je
trouvais qu'on était un peu dur juste
mais le contexte le contexte fait que le
macronisme d'origine a évolué aussi
parce que il y a eu covid parce que la
guerre en Ukraine parce que l'infle donc
voilà donc quand même là-dessus bon il y
a eu un peu de solide et voilà
maintenant effectivement on a
l'impression que dans cette dans cette
évanescence pour reprendre le mot de
Benjamin Morel et bien il ne reste que
l'écume des choses c'est-à-dire la
communication et je trouve étrange
que Gabriel hatal dont on ne peut panier
l'extrême habilité d'une manière
générale face ceci à ce moment-là c'est
c'est c'est ça me paraît d'une d'une
grande maladresse alors vous faites bien
d'ailleurs de de le de le mentionner
parce que ça m'avait échappé pour tout
vous dire et tout ce que j'espère pour
lui c'est que ça va échapper à de
nombreux Français parce que franchement
je trouve que c'est pas du tout le tour
à adopter en ce momentie je sais pas si
les Français ont tous cette vision là
parce que je pense que Gabriel Atal sur
les réseaux sociaux sur sa manière de
communiquer il est quand même plus
adapté à une population jeune
qu'Emmanuel Macron avait du mal he même
ses essais Instagram et tout c'était pas
toujours réussi même quand il était avec
des youtubeurs ça marche quand même un
petit peu moi ce qui me semble plus
choquant c'est la communication en effet
très flamboyante et puis ce décrochage
avec les préoccupations des Français et
des Françaises qu'on voit depuis les
premiers déplacements de Gabriel Atal
nouveau Premier ministre il a beaucoup
de communication c'est très beau et on
lui renvoie des problèmes que le
macronisme n'a pas réussi à régler
depuis tant d'années donc il y a un
principe de réalité qui revient avec
cette communication qui est pourtant
bonne alors dans la disruption il y
avait la volonté de faire autrement vous
souvenez du grand débat du Conseil
national de la refondation des
rencontres de de Saint-Denis du du
rendez-vous avec la nation toutes ces
tentatives était censé illustrer la
méthode du nouveau monde elles ont fait
plutôt choublanc là encore parce que les
institutions étaient trop fortes jein
Morel je dirais pas qu'elles étaient
trop fortes en réalité c'est-à-dire que
prenez par exemple la convention
citoyenne sur le climat c'est quelque
chose ce qui a été mal organisé mal
pensé mais si ça avait été bien organisé
bien pensé avec un vrai débouché aurait
pu fonctionner elle a plutôt bien
fonctionné sur la fin de vie la
convenion C oui parce qu'en réalité
quand vous parlez de la fin de vie bah
si vous voulez souvent quand on vient
voir les consalistes on dit oui mais ça
c'est impossible vous comprenez la 5è
République et cetera la réalité c'est
que sur les conventions citoyennes il y
a plein d'exemples partout dans le monde
donc on sait ce qu'il faut faire et ce
qu'il ne faut pas faire la fin de vie on
sait que ça peut marcher question de
valeur vous réunissez les citoyens et
cetera si vous avez un vrai débouché à
la fin et une vraie publicité du débat
on sait que ça peut fonctionner idaime
d'ailleurs sur les questions de Ric et
cetera c'est pas le grand méchant loup
il y a la moitié des des États
américains qui utilisent le RIC personne
n'a rétabli la peine de mort via un RIC
donc on pourrait avancer sur ce type de
sujet mais je dirais qu'il y a une forme
de crispation de l'ensemble du monde
politique c'est pas les institutions
c'est aujourd'hui une grande partie du
monde politique qui se considère comme
étant en porte à fau sur ces sujets pour
ce qui est d'Emmanuel Macron et là je
rejoins ce qui a été dit ça a souvent
été des gadgets de sortie de crise face
au gilet jaune je sors le grand débat
face à la face à la crise du climat je
sors et bien justement pour con ça avec
les gilets jaunes la convention
citoyenne pour le climat le problème
c'est que ces outilslà s'il doivent
vraiment être pérenes et fonctionner et
bien il faut les institutionnaliser faut
pas les considérer comme étant des
palliatifs pour sortir d'une crise alors
l RIC je rappelle que c'était le fameux
référendum intiative citoyenne bon il y
a une chose qui change pas c'est que
depuis un an et demi il y a toujours pas
de majorité absolue à l'Assemblée
nationale du coup l'exécutif semble
temporiser voir contourner l'obstacle on
va en parler avec Quentin calm qui nous
joint bonsoir Quentin bonsoir matthieur
alors Emmanuel Macron a revendiqué
encore une fois j'allais dire une
nouvelle méthode pour ce début 2024
exactement ça se voit d'ailleurs très
concrètement au Parlement Mathieu quand
on estpluche l'ordre du jour des
prochaines semaines très peu de textes
d'initiative gouvernemental très peu de
projet de loi seul texte majeur avec un
enjeu symbolique le Sénat s'en par de
l'inscription de l'IVG dans la
Constitution le texte sera débattu le 28
février à partir de de 16h30 après et
bien le vote qui est intervenu la
semaine dernière à l'Assemblée nationale
parmi les seuls textes déjà annoncés une
loi agricole présentée à la fin du mois
au moment du salon d'agriculture
également dans les tuyaux de nouvelles
restructions dans les règles
d'indemnisation chômage prévu au 1emier
semestre 2024 mais quelque chose me dit
que ce grand calme n'est pas dû au
hasard qutin exactement on va arrêter de
faire des lois ce sont les propos
rapportés d'Emmanuel Macron en conseil
des ministres il y a 15 jours il a dit
également face au parlementaires de la
majorité c'était le 15 janvier on a pris
beaucoup de lois ces 18 derniers mois
beaucoup de ces lois sont à décliner sur
le terrain a ainsi rapporté le Parisien
il y a beaucoup de choses qu'on peut
faire hors texte ce n'est pas simplement
le fait de faire moins de loi on a fait
autant de textes dans les premiers mois
de cette mandature que sous la
précédente app plaidé le président de la
République il l'a dit également le
lendemain lors de la grande conférence
de presse c'était le 16 janvier on
écoute je pense que beaucoup de choses
sont possibles et je ne cède pas à
l'esprit de
résignation que je vois quand même à
l'œuvre il y a beaucoup de choses qui
nous inquiètent légitimement parce que
beaucoup de changements sont en cours
parce qu'on a vécu tant de
crise mais je crois que si nous savons
travailler ardemment avec beaucoup de
bon sens d'efficacité sans doute moins
de lois mais plus d'action concrète avec
une détermination sans
faille nous aurons des résultats au
service à la fois du quotidien des
Français mais aussi pour préparer
l'avenir de la nation alors en coulisse
on note bien que c'est la loi
immigration qui a marqué le président de
la République même s'il avait déjà
plaidé Mathieu pour être précis pour
moins de lois et plus de liberté et
d'action c'était son expression c'était
en avril 2023 le président en fait il
prend Act je le disais tout à l'heure de
la situation issue des législatives de
2022 il a pas de majorité exactement
Emmanuel Macron ne dispose pas ne
dispose que d'une majorité relative il
est donc coincé entre l'aile gauche de
renaissance et les alr d'où l'idée idé
de passer par des textes plus courts
plus précis autre idée passer par décret
mais ces décrets sont limités dans leur
champ d'action en tout cas pour les
sénateurs cela signe une année 2024
assez calme écoutez le LR Roger kucci ça
n'a rien à voir avec une volonté de
faire de meilleurs textes mais plus à
voir avec le fait que au bout de 25 493
et du fait qu'il y a pas de majorité de
des difficultés qu'on a vu pour les
retraites comme pour l'immigration le
gouvernement va essayer de ne pas trop
venir devant le Parlement ce qui la
réalité ce qui va se passer en réalité
c'est qu'on va voir un gouvernement à
mon avis en grande partie vitrifié et ne
incapable d'action parce que sans
majorité on devrait en savoir plus en
tout cas le 8 février c'est jeudi
Mathieu puisquil y a un séminaire
gouvernemental est prévu pour caler
aussi le calendrier des réformes merci
Quentin gouverné par décret par décision
c'est aussi une une forme de pragmatisme
Sophie Cogard
oui tout à fait en faut reconnaître que
euh c'est pas faute d'avoir essayé de
faire
autrement et mais en effet le le enfin
l'effet
dévastateur euh à tort ou a raison de de
l'usage des 493 dans l'opinion publique
exigeait un changement de méthode la
question c'est en fait l'arbitrage se
fera entre des entre ce qu'on peut faire
par des c d'un côté et effectivement
quand on dit des quand Emmanuel Macron
dit des textes de loi plus court et
cetera comme si tout à coup lui avait
été révélé le secret magique de
l'efficacité gouvernementale mais c'est
pas ça c'est que si vous faites le
compte comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure des textes qui ont réussi à
trouver une majorité au Parlement ce
sont tous des textes courts et à ces
techniques donc en fait il va y avoir
une une sorte de de saucissonnage euh de
de de de l'ambition de réforme donc il
va y avoir des petits textes
effectivement qui vont occuper si j'ose
dire euh le Parlement députés et
sénateurs mais plus jamais enfin il y a
un côté plus jamais ça euh plus jamais
les retraites et plus jamais la loi
immigration c'est c'est c'est un enfin
c'est un pur cauchemar alors gouverneré
par décret ou par décision ministérielle
ça n'empêche pas la grogne Émilie
c'était aujourd'hui le deè la deuxième
grève des professeurs euh en moins d'une
semaine oui l'année 2024 elle s'annonce
mouvement pour la mère des batailles de
Gabriel hatal C syndicats encouragé la
greffe d'aujourd'hui ils ont considéré
que la première avait été un succès avec
47 % de gviste en collège et en lycée il
parle même d'un rebond fort et durable
dès le mois de mars donc surprise leur
revendication une hausse des salaire la
défense de l'école publique mais aussi
bien sûr le rejet des dispositions qui
sont lancées par le gouvernement la
réforme du lycée professionnel et le
choc des savoir un choc des savoirs qui
avait pour ambition de d'élever le
niveau des élèves voilà c'est l'idée il
s'agit de créer des groupes de niveau en
mathématique et en français les bons
d'un côté les moins bons de l'autre il
seraiit moins nombreux en classe ce
dispositif il a marché dans certains
pays comme l'Irlande et le Royaume-Uni
ça a marché pour réhausser le niveau
mais pour les profs c'est synonyme de
tri social on risque de stigmatiser les
élèves les plus en difficulté c'est
aussi pour eux le retour d'un modèle
passéiste conservateur certains me
disent même réactionnaire il faut dire
que certaines études montrent qu'une
telle organisation a souvent tendance à
aider les plus doués à s'améliorer à
l'inverse quand on mixe les élèves on
dit que ça a un effet bénéfique sur la
progression des moins bons et même sur
leur bien-être des personnalités
politiques comme Marine Tondelier Boris
Valot et des enseignants ont publié
mi-décembre dans la dans le Monde une
tribune pour annoncer la fin de la
démocratisation scolaire avec ce retour
des classes à profil mais c'est aussi la
question des moyens qui est posé par les
enseignants oui tout à fait et ce
annoncés par Gabriel Atal quand il était
ministre de l'éducation nationale ne
semble pas suffisant on parle de 4
milliards d'euros en plus sur un budget
de près de 68 milliards d'euros on
estime à 2300 le nombre de professeurs
qui serait nécessaire en supplément pour
ces groupes de niveau alors que le
métier c'est pas une surprise c'est
attire de de moins en moins de candidats
en math par exemple 25 % des postes ne
sont pas pourvu PAP Ndi le précédent
ministre de l'Éducation avait quant à
lui lancé le choc d'attractivité qui n'a
pas donné de résultat donc méfiance pour
ses formule choc qui parle de choc merci
beaucoup Émilie je voudrais qu'on aborde
maintenant un nouveau chapitre qui pose
question celui de la transition
écologique car avec la suspension du
plan
écofyo la remise en cause des 4 % de
jacher imposé par la politique agricole
commune c quand même une des seules
mesures vertes de cette politique
agricole commune ben les mesures
annoncées par Gabriel Atal pour calmer
la colère des agriculteurs ont déclenché
la colère des écolos écoutez marine
Tondelier on a parlé la secrétaire
nationale du parti les
écologistes d'entendre des gens qui nous
disent make or Planet great again je
sais pas quoi qui se font passer pour
des écolos quand c'est le temps des
campagnes et qui s'essui les pieds sur
leur engagement aussitôt élu Emmanuel
Macron en avril 2022 dans son meeting de
Marseille il avait dit ce quinena sera
écologiste où il ne sera pas
malheureusement si s'il était pas bon ce
serait réglé mais il est on le vit on le
subit ce qu'il est en train de faire là
c'est pas juste un petit coup de comme
c'est qu'il met en danger la santé de
nos enfants les générations futures la
biodiversité c'est pas un jeu c'est un
vrai recul Luc schmidth c'est un recul
mais c'est pas seulement à une question
écologique je voudrais insister
là-dessus c'est-à-dire que au fond
pourquoi est-ce que c'est si compliqué
de réformer l'agriculture c'est parce
que ça a été beaucoup dit mais il y a
un/ers des agriculteurs qui n'ont pas de
revenu correct il y a évidemment un
sujet environnemental et de santé comme
le disait marine Tondelier il y a aussi
un sujet économique et il y a une
politique agricole commune ça se passe
dans une imbrication entre l'Europe et
la France et du coup c'est pas seulement
un recul environnemental c'est aussi me
semble-t-il une incapacité à aborder ce
qu'on pourrait appeler des politiques
sociales moi c'est ça qui m'a marqué
dans dans le recul par elle n'est pas la
seule à le dire je pense à Daniel
conbendit par exemple qui a été
longtemps un soutien d'Emmanuel Macron
et qu' le disait ce weekend dans la
tribune dimanche Emmanuel Macron comme
la plupart des gouvernements a mis fin à
son ambition écologique alors sur la
question écologique ce qui est
intéressant c'est que comme comme le
disait d'ailleurs marine tondolier il le
revendique au moment où il l'abandonne
en fait c'est intéressant parce que
quand on regarde le premier quinquena
euh Édouard Philippe a renoncé à à
assumer le renoncement à Notre-Dame des
Landes à l'aéroport à côté de Nantes il
y a eu un renoncement au projet Europa
City en Île-de-France il y a eu comme le
rappelait Benjamin Morel la convention
citoyenne pour le climat et donc il y a
eu beaucoup de choses et il y a eu un
certain nombre de lois qui étaient en
fait des lois plutôt intéressantes sur
la question écologique comme la loi a
Galim par exemple qui portait sur
l'agriculture et l'alimentation donc un
vrai calendrier il y a aussi une loi sur
lesmobilités durbl et on peut pas dire
que ces lois contrairement à ce que dit
Emmanuel Macron dans son son espèce de
plettoyer antidroit qui m'a beaucoup
frappé tout à l'heure on peut pas dire
que ces lois étaient inutiles le seul
sujet c'est qu'ensuite elles ont été mal
appliquées et qu'au fond elles n'ont pas
fait bouger le rapport de force
économique donc moi je dirais un premier
mandat où on n'assume pas tant que ça
l'écologie mais où ensuite quand on se
met à l'assumer ça m'a rappelé Nicolas
sarkozizy qui en 2011 salon de
l'agriculture après avoir fait le Grenel
de l'environnement avait dit l'écologie
ça commence à bien faire le sujet c'est
qu'en fait sur l'écologie il faut être
opiniâtre euh c'est transformer le
modèle économique social et donc ça ne
rapporte pas électoralement
immédiatement et quand on est dans une
espèce de désorientation comme je disais
tout à l'heure au fond on dit une chose
et on fait son contraire mais peut-être
qu'on avait envie de le faire et puis
qu'on se dit ah mais c'est trop
difficile et moi ce qui me frappe c'est
que dans l'attitude d'Emmanuel Macron
qui a plutôt fait des choses parfois
assez difficiles par rapport à au camp
de la droite par exemple renoncer à l'
l'aéroport notred-ame des Landes moi
j'ai trouvé que c'était chapeau ne pas
faire Europa City trou ça très bien les
différ exactement la convention
citoyenne pour le climat comme le disait
tout à l'heure Benjamin Morel c'était
une expérimentation très intéressante
mais on voit qu'à chaque fois il
n'arrive pas à penser les choses
jusqu'au bout au fond il fait une
convention citoyenne pour le climat mais
il sait pas quelle conclusion on tirer
il se dit tiens ils ont fait 149
propositions il y a une loi clim mais
écoutez cette loi elle est elle a ni que
ni tête en fait c'est-à-dire que elle
renonce à énormément de propositions
assez intéressantes et en même temps
elle met en place le zéro
artificialisation nette qui est une
mesure que je trouve très forte mais
sans réfléchir à ses modalités
d'application donc il y a quelque chose
sur le décalage entre le droit et la
réalité qui nous a sauté à la figure
après le premier quinc d'Emmanuel Macron
sur l'écologie on peut pas faire
seulement l'écologie par le haut ça
tombe du ciel non ça tombe pas du ciel
l'écologie il faut associer les
oppositions les élus de terrain et au
fond il est confronté à ça et donc il
peut pas faire d'écologie dans son deuxè
mandat justement Benjamin Morel est-ce
que comme circonstance atuinante les
Français sont pas un peu schizophrènes
parce qu'ils réclam des mesures pour
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique en même temps quand elles
arrivent ben ils traînent des pieds bien
sûr mais si vous voulez ce type de
rhtorique que je vous reproche Pasin
mais qui souvent est celle de du monde
politique du monde journalistique et
cetera qui dis les Français sont pas
cohérents oui parce qu'en fait l'opinion
n'est pas formée autrement dit mais je
nous mets dedans oui bien sûr non mais
nous aussi sans doute mais entre revenus
transition écologique et cetera faire le
lien et comprendre que ce qui met
désagréable aujourd'hui et mais
désagréable également demain en matière
de transition écologique aujourd'hui en
matière de revenu tout est lié c'est pas
tout à fait évident et là il y a un
travail j'aime pas non plus ce mot mais
je l'emploie quand même pour l'occasion
de pédagogie du politique et on en
revient toujours à ça quand vous êtes
dans une logique mouvementiste en disant
ça ça plaît aujourd'hui je le fais ça ça
plaît plus donc du coup je l'enlève mais
en revanche je fais ça parce que ça
plaît vous ne construisez pas de vision
du monde vous savez c'est assez
intéressant de voir que la notion
d'idéologie est devenue un gros mot vous
êtes idéologue c'est pas bien ça veut
dire quoi idéologie c'est le rapport
cohérent entre des idées et si jamais
les vieux partis avaient une idéologie
et n'en faisait pas il y a quelques DESC
Seigner un gros mot c'est parce que
justement cette vision du monde
structurée qui faisait que bah si je
fais la transition écologique ça a telle
implication mais je vais agir sur
parfois ça enferme aussi un petit peu
les ça peut enfermer certes mais
j'entends bien mais en même temps si
jamais vous avez un tas d'idées
totalement incohérentes et
conjoncturelles elle ne font pas système
si elles ne font pas système et bien
tout l'ensemble s'effondre il faut une
dou de pragmatisme mais la politique
c'est pas la gestion sinon on ferait pas
de politique il y aurait pas d'élection
on aurait simplement des fonctionnaires
et il gérerait l'état si on fait de la
politique c'est justement pour faire
s'affronter des visions cohérentes du
monde ou qui se veulent cohérent et ça
évidemment bah c'est peut-être un monde
perdu mais c'est un monde qui avait
quand même ses avantages alors
j'aimerais qu'on termine cette émission
juste pour pour ne pas zapper ce sujet
sur la question européenne parce que la
crise agricole aura vu aussi plusieurs
ministres s'en prendre à la politique
européenne celle là même que votre
pourtant les macronistes quand ils sont
au Parlement européen écoutez par
exemple Marc Phen on peut pas avoir une
pâqu je le dis très simplement très
tranquillement très
pacifiquement mais qui se soit à ce
point complexe et qui se soit à ce point
incompréhensible tant pour parfois nos
administrations que pour nos
agriculteurs est-ce qu'on est dans un
vrai tournant dans le discours européen
euh de de de des macronistes alors euh
je vais aller du particulier au général
très sincèrement je trouve que un
ministre de l'agriculture ne devrait pas
dire ça euh c'est un argument qui est
total enfin c'est tellement éculé le le
politicien français qui vient expliquer
que c'est la faute de l'UR
en expliquant vraiment qu'il y a une
usine à gaz là-bas à Bruxelles et que c
effrayant je trouve enfin pardon c'est
des mots un peu fort mais je trouve ça
un peu indigne en fait sont les mots des
populistes bah pas loin pas loin
c'est-à-dire comme que comme sur
d'autres sujets et là j'eneviens au
général moi je suis frappé jusqu'à
présent on en est qu'au début du début
hein donc je veux pas préjuger de la
forme que va prendre la la campagne du
du camp macroniste pour les européenes
mais jusqu'à présent des propos de Marc
fen jusqu'à ce qui est euh comment dire
comment à être insyé en terme de
souveraineté le discours pour le CP unot
un mot du camp d'en face la souveré
absolument le discours de politique
général de Gabriel Atal qui a tellement
assisté sur la singularité française la
fierté française et cetera c'est très
bien tout ça mais c'est en décalage et
même en décrochage
avec l'ensemble du vocabulaire et de
l'univers mental qui était véhiculé par
Emmanuel Macron lors du discours de la
Sorbonne très tôt dans son premier
quinquena et même dans la campagne de
2019 où
souvenez-vous le le le maître slogan
c'était les progressistes contre les
populistes l'Europe c'était l'espoir
c'était l'horizon VO exactement alors
avec des dangers c'est-à-dire que dire
moi ou le chaos je n'ai jamais pensé que
ça faisait forcément une bonne politique
à long terme mais ce qui est fascinant
c'est quand même ce
décrochage à la fois langagier et
conceptuel si on ose le mot en l'espace
de même pas 5 ans Lucile schmi vous
partagez sentiment sur cette infleion TR
oui oui je pense que en tout cas
l'agriculture fait perdre fait perdre la
tête c'estàdire que il est clair que le
discours de Gabriel Atal aux
agriculteurs est en rupture complète
avec cette cet engagement européen de
d'Emmanuel Macron que moi je pense
qu'Emmanuel Macron est a encore un
engagement européen en fait je pense que
le discours là on nous dit beaucoup ils
sont unis comme tout et cetera moi je
pense que là le discours qu' a tenu
Gabriel àal je n'imagine pas Emmanuel
Macron qui avait parlé de souveraineté
européenne le tenir après le problème
c'est que sur la politique agricole
commune s'engage effectivement comme
vous le disiez un populisme qui en fait
est le récit du rassemblement national
et que moi je crois que ça veut dire que
le rassemblement national qui avait déjà
exme aussi voté la pâac faut le rappeler
hein oui exactement et qui avait une
extrême avance dans les sondage et ben
elle va se conforter je crois que là ça
s'est structuré et je pense qu'à
l'évidence à moins que je sais pas un
homme une femme providentielle ne
surgisse pour conduire cette liste aux
Européennes et que ce soit quelqu'un qui
ne sera pas Emmanuel Macron mais qui ait
un engagement européen aussi fort je
rappelle qu'en 2019 en fait c'est
Emmanuel Macron qui a permis au camp
présidentiel de faire un très bon score
autour de 23 juste derrière le
rassemblement nationale donc
l'agriculture fait perdre la tête il y a
le salon de l'agriculture à la fin du
mois de février et ça va continuer parce
que ça va être encore l'angoisse par
rapport au fait que ça pourrait
reprendre parce que les agriculteurs ont
dit qu'il suspendaient juste la
mobilisation et donc là je pense qu' a
quelque chose qui s'est passé autour de
la perte de sens à moins qu'Emmanuel
Macron ne rectifie le tir effectivement
en 2017 il y avait eu le grand discours
de la Sorbonne il y avait aussi un grand
discours à Athènes et donc il y avait
quelque chose qui qui raisonnait il
s'est heuré aussi a des résistances de
la part de de nos partenaires européen
c'est que le discour de la Sorbonne tout
le monde ne l'a pas accepté parmi les 27
est-ce que c'est Emmanuel Macron qui a
fait un revirement ou est-ce que c'est
aussi l'Europe qui marche un peu de
travers il a moins reviré sur ce sujet
que sur bien d'autres ça fait partie
quand même des colonnes vertébrales
relativement structurel et en effet je
souscris sur le côté je dirais assez pas
anecdotique mais en tout cas assez
incident d'une gestion de crise sur
lequel ben vous devez quand même agir
pour essayer d'éteindre l'incendie après
sur le fond vous avez un Emmanuel Macron
qui reste quand même très européen dans
son discours mais en effet l'Europe
c'est compliqué à réformer il vous faut
l'unanimité pour réformer les traités et
on a beau dire l'Europe nous impose des
choses et cetera je rappelle que pour
avoir une majorité au conseil notamment
une majorité qualifiée vous passez
difficilement sans la France donc il y a
quand même je dirais des jeux dans les
qu les gouvernements sont engagés et si
vous voulez réformer au niveau européen
aujourd'hui vous avez un grand nombre de
blocage évidemment on peut parler de
Victor Orban Victor orbane n'est pas
vraiment le problème quand vous allez à
Berlin et Emmanuel Macron est allé
quelqu fois à Berlin vous rendez compte
que les volontés les véléités d'avancer
de Berlin sont très très limité que
l'allié potentiel que Emmanuel Macron
s'est cherché à un moment c'est-à-dire
Rome avec l'élection de mélonie c'est
plus difficile et donc ce faisant
aujourd'hui qui pour embarquer une vraie
réforme de l'Europe c'est loin loin
d'être une évidence on a une Europe qui
de manière globale et relativement
malade et donc ce faisant bah c'est pas
la France SAB clair dans un système où
vraiment la codécision le dialogue entre
institution et état ne permet pas comme
ça d'imposer de manière très bonne
àartiste un choix une option une vision
qui peut toute seule faire avancer des
choses sophieard pour pour terminer
toujours pas de tête de liste pour la
majorité présidentielle à 5 mois de ce
scrutin européen c'est ça en diton ben
ça en diton sur effectivement le le le
l'équation impossible dont parlait
Lucile Schmid c'est-à-dire trouver le le
l'oiseau
rare
l'incroyable Phénix qui sera capable de
de retourner la situation ou du moins de
combler l'écart avec le rassemblement
national mais en c'était un peu la
mission de Gabriel Atal oui alors
effectivement Gabriel Atal est là pour
ça aussi enfin il va quand même falloir
qu'il a une tête de liste malgré
[Rires]
toutm c'est se moquer du monde de pas
ouvrir la campagne européennne comme ça
on l'impression c'est c'est quand même
un parti qui escamote parfois un peu les
campagnes en tout cas c'est sigueux
c'est désorienté et puis par rapport à
ce que disait Benjamin Morel et Sophie
coagard il y a un sujet vous savez au
niveau européen du pouvoir collectif et
en fait c'est la difficulté d'Emmanuel
Macron je crois qu'il a souvent eu
raison sur ce qu'il disait sur l'Europe
puissance sauf qu'il avait raison tout
seul et qu'il a jamais réussi à être
moins seul et donc il y a pas que des
cons en fait chez les autres chefs
d'État ou de gouvernement et on a ce ce
vous savez on a on a ce mythe du
français arrogant qui existe fortement à
Bruxelles et ce myth a été alimenté par
cette pratique et on peut avoir raison
contre tous mais du coup ça ça marche
pas et bien je vous propose de terminer
ce débat par ce ce constat je sais pas
s'il est très optimiste merci à tous les
trois d'y avoir participé je rappelle
vos ouvrages la terni de la médiocrité
pour vous Sophie coangard aux éditions
de l'Observatoire la France en miette
aux éditions du Saer pour vous Benjamin
Morel et puis
Emmanuel Macron à contetemps chez Bayard
pour vous Lucile schmidth merci à tous
les trois